hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar don't hesitate learn
how to step up your library prep with
new biomech life series genomics sample
prep work stations I'm to do work of
levers and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminars
presented by lab routes leading
scientific social networking website and
provider our virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by beckman
coulter life sciences beckman coulter
life sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex biomedical testing
more than 275,000 ethnic cultures for
certain operate in both diagnostics and
life sciences laboratories on seven
continents for over 75 years our
products have been making a difference
in people's lives by improving the
productivity of medical professionals
and scientists supplying critical
information for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions for
research and discovery to learn more
about beckman coulter life sciences
please visit www in comm let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing a presentation just click on the
support button found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at lower left I now present
today's speakers Zack Smith a senior
applications scientists at beckman
coulter life sciences in this role that
automates propriety and third-party
next-generation sequencing NGS kits he
holds a master's degree in environmental
science and a bachelor's degree in
biology from Indiana University Zack
also worked at the University Center for
genomics and bioinformatics to the
project scientist before joining beckman
coulter life sciences in 2014 Zack Smith
will now begin his presence
thank you very much for the introduction
and thank you to everyone for joining us
today for this live webinar my name is
Zack Smith and i'll be taking you
through innovations that we have created
for NGS sample prep you on our new
biomech iseries platforms so just
briefly here's my disclaimer obviously
we all trademarks belong to their
respective owners so for the outline
today we're going to be going briefly
over the biomed bottom I series
automated workstation for those of you
who did not attend the first part of
this three-part series and then i'll be
taking you on a case study of automating
biomarker discovery from FFPE samples
using our biomech I've series automated
workstation with our former pure DNA
kits that we sell and the illuminator
cgx own kit so the i series represents
an expansion of the biomech product line
that we are proud that we launched sles
earlier this year we have obviously we
have our biomech for thousands a very
low end of our automation offering
followed by the NX and then the other
one of the previous platforms is the FX
we're proud to add the biomech i5 and i7
and we are able to extend these
workstations and see larger integrated
systems so we have the ability to offer
a automated solution for a variety of
different media users and throughputs
the bottom of nine series automated
workstation offers a variety of new
features that will allow you for a more
simplistic workflow allowed you to
increase your efficiency improve your
liability and support and make the
system more adaptable to extend the
scale and research we reach of your
research I'm going to be going over each
one of those major points in the
following few slides very quickly so
that we can familiarize ourself with the
platform so the ice series of automated
workstation comes in two sizes of
another earlier the i-5 which is the
sort of minute mid-range size and the i7
which is the larger of the two the i-5
instrument comes with either a span pod
or a multi-channel pod and with the i7
you can have
span a multichannel a dual multi-channel
or a do our or a hybrid with one each so
there's a two platforms and six
different pipetting offerings the
American configurations that are
available in these new systems the
biomech software if you're familiar with
biomech now there's about a 20-minute
learning curve for the new software so
the software has been redesigned to work
on Windows 10 it's been restyle eyes but
if you're again if you're familiar with
our current software you'll have no
trouble transitioning into our new
software the other thing we've added to
the system is a large status light bar
on top which you can see glowing in the
dark on the bottom left that allows you
to monitor the system status from across
the lab quite easily we've also added an
LED illuminated deck to improve
visibility when loading and unloading
the instrument with lab where and to
allow you to watch pipetting more
effectively so it really is quite handy
the systems have improved debt capacity
so the ice evan has 45 deck positions
compared to approximately 20 on the FX
the i5 has approximately 25 dec
positions compared to approximately 12
on the NX so you get a lot more space on
your deck the overall instrument
footprint however is not a personally
larger so we're just we were able to
create all that extra space by making
the deck more dense we now have a
rotating gripper on each pod which
allows you to pick pick up labware move
it around the deck and more efficiently
so there's no position on the deck
that's not invertible now which is
really handy our multi-channel head has
been completely redesigned so we
actually use force loading now for our
tips on the multi-channel pot so there's
no more tip loader on the deck we also
offer a selective tip loading on the
multi-channel pods and as standard which
means that you can load anywhere from 1
to 96 tips and for the spam Todd we've
introduced individual probe calibration
to allow for more accurate sub
microliter pipetting the deck itself is
a grid-based pattern so we instead of
having a one piece of metal where you
we locate your Alps and very station you
know very specific locations the deck
plates are individually located on the
deck and then they have grids built on
top of them so you can have more
flexibility in how you're laying out
your system and the other thing about
the new platform is you'll notice how
open the design is so that allows us to
integrate devices off the back and off
the front or backing off the sides more
effectively so additionally we have we
offer enclosures on these systems so
they come come with them include built
enclosure or without we also offer HEPA
for each protein closure option we also
have new onboard cameras one built into
the towers which allow you to remote
monitor the instrument while it's
running and if there is an error
biomedical retain up to 30 seconds of
video before and after the error to
allow you or one of our engineers to
identify what the problem is and fix it
additionally we're offering our pro
service which allows us to remote into
the assuming of course that your IT
department will allow us to do so allows
us to remote into the biomech controller
and get the files we need in case you
need a service of some variety with an
application or there's a particular
software question that you have and then
obviously we're maintaining our current
transport training program and
application support to get you up and
running so we Beckman culture works with
a wide variety of partners and we have
automation solutions that help drive
acceleration and virtually in a number
of different ways so we have proactive
method development so part of my job
internally is to go out and automate our
Beckman chemistry as well as third-party
chemistry such as alumina or a baby on
our biometric series and so we do that
proactively working with the reagent
vendors to identify what kit that
they're seeing demand for and you know
get an automation solution available for
those two sub speed up your your work as
researchers we also work over the
variety of companies that work for
cell-based assays so obviously Beckman
culture is a member of the Danaher
family we long with forte bio and sy x
and so we all work very closely together
as an ax
companies so that gives us options for a
variety of different integration you
know collaborations for NGS primarily
it's that's working with the region
vendors for their nucleic acid you know
NGS sample Previn nucleic acid sample
preparation so we also work with a few
metrics as well for microarray sandal
prep so I series really does a lot for
helping you know expand your your
efficiency and turnaround time for
method development so the screenshot you
see here on the on the bottom of the
slide is basically at a comparison
comparison sheet between our current
methods that they're to you know exist
on the FX and what we're time savings
and whatnot what you achieve with the
iseries so for example with alumina
stranded mrna for the FX we have to do
it in terms of there's at least one
manual deck reset because of the deck
capacity between at the end of cdna
synthesis whereas that same method on
the iseries i7 can be set up once and
completely walk away in approximately
eight a half hours so you get increased
increased ability to walk away you get
battery on more and and better turn
around time and then we also have a
method card that we can certainly be
happy to send to you with what we've
developed currently and what we're in
the process of implementing on the
iseries so with all that being said i'm
going to dive into a case study of
automating biomarker discovery from FP
samples using the iseries automated
workstation and our form pure DNA kits
as well as the alumina to seek x own kit
so fire markers are National Cancer
Institute defines the biomarkers
biologically molecule having blood or
other fluids that is indicative of a you
know treatment or diseased condition
some biomarkers can take a form of DNA
variants RNA variants or proteins for
DNA variants that come in a wide variety
of flavors you can have single
nucleotide polymorphisms insertions
deletions copy number variants and so
one of the things the researchers really
want to understand is what you know what
is the molecular drivers
welcome to cancer in this particular
research area another thing you'll find
very commonly oncology is FFP DNA so
ffpe stands for fixed form one
paraffin-embedded tissue effectively
what happens is when you go in and have
a biopsy done the tumor are the tissue
is you know is fixed in formalin and
then embedded in paraffin and this
allows the material of the tissue sample
to be stored at room temperature for
decades fairly cheaply so it's you know
it's incredibly easy to perform it's
quite economical as well it's just a few
dollars per block part of the
difficulties of working with it includes
difficult extractions of DNA and the DNA
is frequently damaged due to a variety
of things including double-stranded
breaks demonization and primatene dimers
and then you also get variable yield due
to an even distribution of sample in the
block so you don't necessarily know when
you're going through and flexing the
block into your 10 micron slices where
exactly that tissue is going to be
located so needless to say it's not
everyone's favorite material for working
with but it's what we have so so with
that deccan culture just recently
released a new kit called form of pure
DNA for extracting DNA from ffpe
material and this is the entirety of the
workflow so we take our slice and we'd
be paraffin eyes it by heating it up in
mineral oil we then add our lysis buffer
and proteinase k and digest the tissue
away perform our d cross-linking by
eating the sample up some more and then
we add RNA say to digest away all the
RNA and then we use our solid phase
reversible and mobilization technology
or stripe beads to bind the DNA remove
it from solution a wash it and then
Aleut so as you can see it can extremely
compact workflow and does not require an
expend columns and generally works quite
nicely so nine steps is one optional
centrifuge step no xylene required and
just three temperatures so it's not a
terribly complex workflow makes it quite
easy on automation specialists such as
myself
so this is just some some manual
extraction data that my colleague Jungo
who's the internal application scientist
for reagents generated so as you can see
here comparing FP DNA to supplier qs
yield with horizon breast cancer or
breast lung her loss our large intestine
liver and lung we were able to get
comparable or better yields both in
terms of the quantity of DNA that was
isolated as well as the quality of the
DNA or nanodrop readings in the chart
from the bottom left her bottom right
excuse me so the next question we wanted
to address is because we had heard from
a variety of our customers as well
that's all well and good but what if I
wanted to do a split extraction what if
I wanted to get DNA and RNA out of the
same out of the same sample so John went
back and began working alone and
expanded workflow so the split workflows
here soonish you know shown graphically
but it's it's very similar to the DNA
only workflow so we end up with we form
the deep a reservation and lysis and the
proteinase k treatment and then the
lysate itself is split into two
different two different plates and then
we proceeded to go through and do a DNA
workflow on top and an RNA works well on
the bottom so we allows us to actually
isolate new total nucleic acid from one
sample so this is some comparative arte
yields comparing supplier q supplier
supplier a we also looked at the
pelletier versus orbital shaker on these
so you can see our RNA yields are quite
good that we're getting from stomach and
from you know not obviously not as good
from breast or lung or liver but I'll
Camilla a lot of this is blocked pendant
so I think the yields here are certainly
more than sufficient for most NGS
applications now the other thing we've
noticed our we've shown at a variety of
different locations not just our
internal lab is that the RNA that we're
getting is actually more intact than the
RNA that's derived from come
operable kits so you can see here is
these are bioanalyzer RNA nano traces of
the library are of the RNA that was
derived from using a fork or DNA kit the
blue traces you're seeing in each of the
four images that you're seeing here are
from our kit and the red trace is you're
seeing here from supplier Q's kit so as
you can see we're actually getting some
more higher molecular weight RNA species
with our chemistry which this is pretty
exciting stuff the other thing we did is
we went through and verified that the
RNA that we're using is actually NGS
compatible so we actually ran through
the management the manual we're answered
manually the illumina true see kearney
access kit so this is some more work
that was done by my colleague John so on
the right hand or on my left your right
probably side of the screen you'll see
bioanalyzer traces of the various points
of the library prep and then some
sequencing metrics that Jung Georgia
generated in house on our next seat
platform as you can see be in the insert
link distribution was was pretty tight
the majority of the sample was coming to
the coding region and our transcript
coverage was fairly uniform meaning that
we're not biasing the the library
preparation isn't biased towards one
into the of the RNA or the other so that
was some pretty solid data so for my
part what I did was that we put together
an entire workflow utilizing our
chemistry and our liquid handler and for
the RNA for the DNA extraction of from
the FP blocks and utilizing the alumina
true Sikh XM kit on our liquid handler
for the actual Indians library prep so
as you can see here we we can certainly
provide you with a sectioning option
through our fellow opcode leica with
micro tongue and then we also utilize
the molecular devices spectra max I
three for our fluorimetric assays for
concentration we determine them after
library after nucleic acid extraction
sorry we then would inform so we did the
box section like a microtome with them
was extracted are they DNA
using our form pure DNA kit performed a
QC of the DNA on the liquid handler then
did our library prep on the same
platform and then finally did in gs QC
on the on the platform as well so this
is the debt configuration of the
instrument that I use for this work this
is a biomech I series I seven dual
hybrids with a multi-channel pod and a
span pod so the multi-channel pot in
here in this case is our new 1200
microliter pipetting head on it it'll is
also equipped with a thermo automated
thermocycler ATC we also have the
ability incidentally to Dubai Metro T
robot or an eco dtc if you want
additional walk away time to put in your
thermocycler right on the deck and we
also used a beckman orbital shaker and
one he co static lpa for keeping our
enzyme master mix is cool as you can see
the extra deck past it really does help
a lot so the other thing that these
methods that we've developed in-house
sport is our demonstrated method
interface which is a three-part you know
software interface so the first part of
the software it would be our pie on that
method launcher offering so what we've
come to the realization over the course
of our of our last few years is that the
majority of our users are operators
they're not necessarily programmers and
so by Mac method launcher was designed
to give our operators the ability to
just go up to an interface and select
which meant that they want to run and
not have to dive into the complexities
of the blonic software if they didn't
wish to so they would go to the launcher
they would select run form pure DNA or
they would select you know the NGS
application of interest and then number
two is the method option selector would
then pop up so this is where they are
able to go and configure the workflow to
match the number of samples they're
processing if there's anything that they
want to stop and approve stop points
this is where they would this is where
they would set that up and then once
they've started the run then our guided
lab where setup will go through and step
them through we're on the deck to put
all the pit boxes plates and where to
fill in arrange and troughs
with the various company components that
need to so this is really trying to help
the operators come to the point where
they can go through and set the
instrument up with confidence and reduce
errors so so for our form pure DNA
method so I've got a sort of a workflow
diagram of top so we gone for a manual
protocol we have to be whack slices be
cross nucleus treatment bind to washes
and elution for the automation protocol
we basically do all that as one you know
one general workflow there is
approximately 15 to 20 minutes of
hands-on time for setting the method up
and then there are a variety of you know
of times that you're seeing listed here
so if you're running through and doing
it the bee wax license and Dean cross on
deck and it's approximately four hours
and 45 minutes for 96 up to 96 DNA
samples and one hour and 33 minutes of
the actual nucleic acid you know by and
watch a blue part of the method we also
have meal so effectively you're looking
at about six hours and 15 minutes
approximately 496 DNA samples or six
hours and 30 minutes for up to 96 RNA
only or if we were performing a split
workflow 96 DNA and 96 RNA
simultaneously from the same sections so
one technician with one imac an
approximate hour and a half of hands-on
time could do up to 500 samples a week
with the automation methods that we've
developed as it's currently stands so
I'm too shabby for the biomarker
experiment that we performed here we had
eight tendril eight technical replicates
of horizon HD two hundred reference
materials this is the multiplex FFP
reference material that horizon
diagnostics cells as well as five
different FFP block samples from a
strand two breasts too long on a liver
at very odd pages from three to five
years and we have for technical
replicates for each of those we had 11
10 micron pearl
each of those technical replicates so
here's our FFP DNA yields as calculated
from a pico green set up on the bionic
eye series so horizon samples we had one
sample which horizon number four where
there was not as much material in the
tube as there was the other samples but
I went ahead and ran it anyway I don't
know if they were running to the end of
the block when they were sectioning that
one but as you can see for all the other
samples were getting you know well in
excess of 400 nanograms of
double-stranded DNA out of each of our
horizon samples which was was quite
quite heartening some of which were you
know quite a bit higher than 400
mammograms and then as you can see from
the rest of the samples so 76 of 96 who
are our breasts or our lung samples
sorry breasts as you can see here
there's quite a bit of difference in the
in the yields we're getting and we see
this all the time with FFP material that
there's you know going from section to
section and from block to block we can
see quite a bit of difference in yield
for our breast and liver was so breast
was 110 and 121 and our liver was 107
again we are seeing some variability
yields but certainly more than enough
for what we need to do for our NGS
library prep we also looked at the
sandton at the few of the technical
replicates on the Agilent a station so
this is a genomic tape general screen
tape that was run on our axle on 2200 as
you can see here our horizon sample
obviously has the highest DNA integrity
number of 9.6 but that's not terribly
surprising giving that horizon material
is not terribly you know old by
comparison to the rest of the samples
and this probably has fixed in a more
gentle fashion than the than the
astronauts so our DNA integrity numbers
for the remaining samples are running
from 2.2 to 3.6 but obviously you know
more than enough material to go through
and do our library trap on so in a
separate experiment we're looking at the
split protocol so this was doing the FFP
DNA and RNA on the
biomech I serious system so we have the
DNA yields and a size distribution of
the DNA on top and then for the RNA we
have the yield on the bottom and as well
as the size distribution so this is some
very early access data we just develop
this a few weeks ago so more more work
to come on this particular application
but just to show that we can do it so
for to seek exome to seek exome for
anyone who's familiar with the workflow
it's a much more complicated workflow
than our extraction chemistry so you
start off with a DNA fragmentation and
clean up followed by and repair and size
selection a tailing and after ligation
pcr n plus pcr cleanup and that sort of
section 1 up to the end of library
construction then you quantify the
individual libraries and you pull them
for your hybridization capture and then
there's two rounds of hybridization
capture followed by enrichment pcr and
enrich for pcr clean up our automation
method basically divides those into
three major sections so on the first the
first day you would run a section one
and get that up through your ended
library construction and then section 2
you would run on day two going into the
second hybridization which requires a
minimum of 14 and a half hours of
hybridization and then section 3 is what
you would finish up on the third day and
then the times for processing up to 96
samples or eight tools is included at
the bottom of all as well as some set-up
time estimates obviously I didn't
include the hybridization times because
those were run off deck we do mean as
far as the hybridizations are concerned
that's not really something we recommend
running with the on deck thermal cyclers
generally because the evaporation might
become you know quite a bit of an issue
so for our experiment we had basically
46 Plex tools that we're running so cool
one included all of our FOP samples as
well as one horizon spike and in the
other three pools we replace the block
76 technical replicate with per mega
genomic DNA just to test the the
workflow
to give it some you know this is whatyou
know pristine DNA would look like when
run through the automation there were
some protocol deviation so aluminum did
publish a tech note for working with FFP
material with this kit so we did use
three hundred and grams of FFP DNA input
for library construction as opposed to
one hundred utilized 12 cycles of pcr
for library amplification and 500
nanograms of library going into
hybridization capture so those are all /
illumina's recommendations here we see
some library traces and the final
library am the final library yields that
we're looking at for our individual
libraries so as you can see on the right
we're seeing a genomic DNA library one
of the per mega genomic DNA libraries
and then on the left we're seeing our
FFP library so we had slightly higher
adapter divers in the FFP libraries
compared to the genomic library but that
is to be expected given the some of the
challenges and working with FOP material
it doesn't necessarily like eight as
well or readily or amplify as readily as
our genomic DNA due to the various is
the damage that occurs during the
fixation process but our library yields
were more than sufficient for going
forward into library construction or
into the hybridization capture so the
traces you're seeing on this slide are
our two pools so we took two of these
six flex pools in through hybridization
capture pull one and pool to the traces
are on the left qpcr yields calculated
on the right we're quite high so more
than enough material to go into
sequencing so our in our internal
application slab here in Indianapolis we
have both a next week and a my seek
sequencer from aluminium which was is
extremely handy for generating
sequencing data we don't have to rely on
a vendor or an outside source to do so
so we did a single next seek run with a
two by 76 paired end kit we generated
100 oppression 114 million reads with
ninety six percent of the reads or
higher being your past filter and
identified so we then took the read
and use the true seek whatever sorry we
use the bass bass enrichment three-point
Oh app which uses the Isaac liner and a
variety of other by informatics programs
to map it reads to the reference genome
and first ride you know on target read
enrichment numbers so this is the data
that they are seeing here so in each of
the samples that constitute pool one so
we only seek with one tool in this in
order to get you know fairly decent
definite coverage on our one next secret
our percent read alignments were over
ninety percent in all in all cases our
percent padded read enrichment was
approximately sixty percent for all all
samples so padded rearrangement is the
percent of the reads that are falling
within the designated regions of the
tracy gxm kid I think there's
approximately two hundred and fourteen
thousand regions that are recovered in
that kit so we would use the bed file
from alumina to calculate how many of
those you know how many of our map rates
are falling into those regions of the
regions that are in the kids
approximately ninety nine percent of
them were covered in to end at least 21
X as you can see from the graph below so
that meant that we had a fairly uniform
coverage of our region's and that's
again underscored by the graph who you
know the uniformity of coverage graph
you're seeing on the on the right here
so this is looking at where the reads
are mapping on average for each of the
regions and we're seeing uniformity of
coverage you know greater than ninety
percent for that data one other thing we
looked at was the mean region depth of
coverage so the horizon sample performed
the best with almost 200 x coverage we
did see proximal somewhere around 50 x
coverage total for the lung and sorry
for the breast and the lump and
approximately a hundred x coverage for
the liver sample when we on average
across all the regions when we looked at
the target region depth of coverage and
broke it down by one x 10 x or 20 or 50
x coverage the horizon sample obviously
outperformed all of them so ninety
percent of the reasons were covered at
50 x or higher the you know the liver
sample
forms they go the next best with
properly seventy percent of the region's
covered at 50 extra higher the other two
other samples you can see there as well
I believe if we'd had more sequencing
coverage from I seek run or additional
neck seek runs that because you know
driven these numbers up substantially so
another thing we wanted to look at was
what are some of the snv's were seeing
in each of these samples so we looked at
the metrics coming off of the true Sikh
enrichment map and we generated you know
compared to the reference genome you
know anywhere from twenty or twenty
eight thousands of 65,000 snv's that we
observed the most important thing I want
to draw your attention to is this SP
transition to transversion ratio so
there's some work that comes out of the
Broad Institute that suggests that for a
whole exome experiment these numbers
should be a proud of that ratio should
be approximately 2.8 as a way of
measuring how well you're in written how
well your bio informatics pipeline was
mapping the reads to the whole exome and
as you can see here we're running
anywhere from 2.6 to 2.8 so I feel like
that the assembly that we did of the
reads the reference genome using the
true Sikh or using the base base in
Richmond through point O app did a
fairly good job of aligning them
properly and we're not seeing over there
artifacts based on the bio chromatics
part of the pipeline so another thing we
looked at because we had a verizon
sample on deck was the horizon samples
has an expected allele frequency that
they publish on their website for these
samples which is extremely handy it
allows you to verify that your pipeline
for both nucleic acid extraction and for
NGS sample prep is actually observing
the allele frequencies that you should
expect to observe her variety of
different markers so as you can see here
we did quite well as far as comparison
to our expected allele frequencies
compared to what we were able to
identify with the enrichment v3 app so
we did have a couple of dropouts those
were in egfr but those were both you
know less than two person young b allele
expected allele frequency on the horizon
sample was less than two percent
samples I feel like if we've had an
additional sequencing coverage that we
would be able to pull those out
additionally we looked at the parental
line known mutations when we were able
to identify 17 of the 19 parental line
mutations were also detected from our
data even though this was a fairly
limited next week sequencing run so I
feel like we're you know as far as like
being able to find what is there were on
target so finally we also looked
specifically at the liver sample so the
liver sample was was identified from
astron as being biliary tract carcinoma
Sevilla Larry track carcinoma is a
cancer of the bile ducts that generates
extremely small easily metastasized
tumors and again because it's very
deeply it was in the liver it's very
hard that's tect so I went into cosmic
the continuum of somatic mutations in
cancer and pulled out the top 20 genes
that were associated with mutations of
which were associated with biliary tract
cancer of those we were able to identify
the top seven as you can see on the pie
chart right including a number of
varieties in K our number of mutations
identified in kmt to see which is a
otherwise a methyl transferase gene that
wouldn't that has been associated with
this particular variety of cancer our T
p53 mutation actually generated that a
very shortened truncated version of the
p53 protein so it's not surprising that
this this tumor grew very rapidly but we
were able to identify even from our
again from our limited amount of Mexique
data genes that were you know mutations
that were diagnostic of the type of
cancer that the is that the pathology
department has assigned to that
particular variety of cancer so so yeah
it was a fun experiment and so with that
I want to acknowledge my colleagues here
at beckman culture including shelf of
rock is also a next generation you know
applications development scientist like
myself and
the monk boldly Lou has me to patel Amy
Yoder and JP palace who are all members
of the of our internal development team
for the form of your DNA kit as well
believe so Jackson who's our genomics
automation manager so with that I will
be happy to take your questions and
thank you very much for attending thank
you jack for your presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window Zach Smith will
answer as many questions as time permits
and our first question is are all of
your demonstrated methods available with
iseries instruments so that's a great
question so we are in the process of
moving our demonstrated methods over to
the iseries platforms there's been a
number of changes to hardware and the
software so for example the software for
the i series runs on Windows 10 and the
current biomax runs on Windows 7 so
there's a software challenge there and
then there's the increased debt capacity
and the new grippers for example of the
the new platform that is really giving
us an opportunity to look at our current
demonstrated methods and take advantage
of all the new capabilities we have on
the i series so can we make the method
faster can we make it process more
samples can we reduce the number of
interactions that the user needs to to
do with the instrument nor to get a
complete workflow on the deck so we are
in the process of building out that that
demonstrated portfolio for the iseries
right now and we'll be happy to talk
about any specific methods if you would
want to contact us next one is can I use
former pure DNA for RNA isolation yes
you can so we as we covered in the in
the slide deck earlier so we do have a
extraction workflow for harmony for
extracting RNA from SP material using
our form of pure DNA kit can you provide
an example where an NGS method is
shorter or as fewer touch points on an
iseries instrument compared to current
biomech platforms
yes I certainly Kim so with alumina
stranded mrna for example right now on
our FX there the mandatory deck reset at
the end of CME synthesis and then you go
through and do the remainder of library
preparation for the biomech FX that the
whole method runtime is approximately
ten and a half hours or so for the ice
and you know putting the same method on
the i7 we can we have enough deck space
we can put everything on the deck that
we need for the entirety of library
construction from starting with your RNA
all the way through to the end the final
enrichment pcr step and because of the
extra capacity and whatnot of the
multi-channel head we're able to do that
entire 96 sample workflow in about eight
and a half hours so we've saved you know
one touch point and approximately an
hour and a half of processing time as
other Bettman software semi-dark been
updated to work with the iseries
instruments yes so in addition to
biomech we also have dart and sammy have
been updated to work with the new i
series platforms so if you so for those
of you who aren't familiar dart our data
acquisition and reporting tool allows
you to take data in and out of biotech
software from a limb system best way to
think about it is the front porch of
your limbs so if you want to be able to
move data in a now that our repository
between methods you know as the
instrument is processing that's
perfectly fine with there and then sammy
is our larger scheduling software so if
you had if you wanted to run multiple
runs and you want to be able to schedule
them efficiently basically run you know
runs inside of incubation as well you
know cases start of methods and then run
another method inside incubation period
or if you wanted to schedule multiple
runs across multiple instruments Sammy
would sandy would be your ear one so so
yes it's all been updated to run on the
new i series software and instruments if
a variant is not detected do you have to
assume the possibility that that variant
to be less than two percent and
another method or just throw away that
gene info or was the example set up to
show this anomaly so generally for
samples coming from Horizon I tend to
believe that the variants are there when
they when they horizons QC Department
says that they're there so for the
variant below two percent maybe what you
need to do is you need to find a
different NGS kit that's sort of like
amplification based like truesight 215
or 26 for example that 0 that allows you
to do a much higher depth of coverage
true cgx own because your sequencing the
entire exim is not really the best
platform for putting on the the next
week just because you're you're trying
to get a higher depth of coverage over a
much wider a region of the genome and
then maybe an amplification based NGS
application would be better if we're
hunting us small subsection of jeans on
a smaller sequencing instrument what
sort of equipment integrations are
available for iseries platforms so one
of the things that is nice about the new
life series platforms is the ability
extra space we have because of the open
design to allow for more integrations so
we have a you know we've obviously the
plate washers we can put plate readers
there are a couple of integrated
centrifuge options that we that we can
offer as well we can also integrate
robotic arms so if you wanted people to
pass plates in and out of different
liquid handlers we can certainly do that
we actually have an entire department
internally whose job it is sorry is to
integrate third-party devices and make
them work with our system so we'd be
happy to discuss your instrument of
interest in more detail if you'd like
did you give some additional detail on
the deck layout for library preparation
certainly so for I'm just going to slide
back through the presentation real quick
we've got a great screenshot cut the
deck excuse my slide of jumping here so
this is the deck layout that we're we're
looking at right now for serve our
standard and
yes deck for you know the biomech III
seven so we have the ability to put on
an integrated thermocycler in this case
it's the thermo ATC which I have I have
on my system in the lab and we have one
static pelletier in order to keep the
enzyme mastermix is cool while they're
on the deck and we have an orbital
shaker as well for you know shaking our
you know you know basically would you do
an enzyme addition will shake the plate
or if you're doing beam cleanups as well
we'll use our little shaker for that we
also have a not listed here and
highlight that you also have a
multi-channel wash station so we have
the ability to go through and watch our
tips if we want to I also use it for
just waste dispensed for non hazardous
chemicals so we'll just dispense the
waste to their for those of you who are
running so L DTS or sort of more Clinton
or near clinical applications obviously
we can incorporate our automated lab
where feeders that would allow us to
bring more tip boxes and onto the deck
so we're not we're not washing tips and
then we have our seven tip loader
position so as I mentioned earlier the
iseries does not have a pneumatic tip
loader like the biomech effects does
we're basically just using press loading
to load the tips for a multichannel at
these defined Tipler positions and so
you can have as many of those as you
want so it is really convenient because
you don't have to necessary if you have
enough tip lever positions you don't
have to move the tip boxes around to a
location then wait for them to load you
just load and go the other thing you'll
see here is I have in addition to all
that other stuff 27 static positions for
holding tips for the span a pod and lab
lawyer played some reservoirs it really
is a very nice system it's making me
very lazy as an application developer
well thank you i would like to once
again think zack zack smith for his
presentations that do you have any final
comments um well just to thank you all
for your time i realize it was a
in a little bit of a whirlwind but
that's that's okay thank you for hanging
in with us this long and we'll be having
another webinar coming up in a couple
days on cellular applications and we
hope you'll tune in for that one as well
well thank you and yes please remember
this webinar is part of a series in the
next webinar scheduled for Thursday
April twentieth Mike Kowalski PhD will
present advances in cellular automation
registration is open on the labyrinth
website I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information we provided at time of
registration we'd also like to thank our
sponsor veteran culture life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed on
demand through October 18 2017 lab roots
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live again
until next time goodbye